what does it feel like being here what's  it like being here at the Emmys  oh sorry  yeah but it's I'm having fun so much  fun um now  um I see some old faces instead of all  being new so I'm a little more relaxed  okay tell us about squid game season two  what are they gonna do for season two  foreign  really hard right now we're going to  start shooting next year  what was it like when you realized the  show was blowing up and everybody was  watching it everywhere all around the  world how crazy was that  [Music]  um  so surprising it's a pleasant surprise  that everyone across the world are  enjoying the same content the same story  and they find the same points touching  so I think it's just really nice and  great and what about all the kids  wearing squid game outfits everywhere  you turn around  [Laughter]  [Music]